Hello and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
live.
I'm your host, David McKay, who also forgot
his name. I'm known across the internet as
Rawkode,
mostly because all the other good handles were
taken. Now today,
we are taking a look at WebAssembly and
WASC and
we quite literally have the person that wrote
the book on this joining us today. Kevin
Hoffman is a distinguished engineer at Capital One,
the author of programming WebAssembly with Rust and
the technical lead for the WASC project.
Hello, Kevin. How are you? I'm doing good.
Thanks for having me here. No. This is
gonna be awesome. I'm really looking forward to
this.
WebAssembly is a very very cool technology
that I will do my best
to explain it and then you can you
know, come on and just let me know
what I got wrong or hopefully I got
it all right. But anything you wanna add
to that, feel free to go. So my
understanding of WebAssembly
is that it is a big code not
too dissimilar to what the JVM has, I
really hate to make that comparison, but you
know, we work with anyone who writes Java,
works with Java and it get compiled to
a big code.
WebAssembly I think is the same on there's
a runtime isn't a JVM,
it's VA or something within our browsers to
execute that code.
The reason I am quite interested in WebAssembly
is that it comes with a whole bunch
of
sandboxing things that keep it safe from the
rest of the browser.
Is that right?
Yeah. So by and large, it's it's right.
I think whenever whenever I ask someone, you
know, what is WebAssembly,
the first thing they they invariably say is
that it's
a VM that runs in the browser.
And
my for my own
personal purposes, I have no intention
of doing anything with the browser.
All of the stuff that I do with
WebAssembly
is
servers and in the cloud and on the
edge.
So it is a virtual machine,
but the browser is just one of many
hosts.
As long as the the as long as
the host knows how to read that bytecode,
it can be anywhere from
VM running in the cloud to
Raspberry Pi or something even smaller.
Yeah. That's a that's a great point. Like,
well, the WebAssembly,
if I code and APIs and all that
were initially defined to maybe, you know, speed
up the computational aspect of browser
stuff.
Is that there's no reason run times for
that can't exist outside of the browser, which
is what the WASC project does, if I'm
not mistaken. Do you wanna just give us
the the, you know, the ten second pitch
of what WASC is?
Sure. So the the ten second pitch is
that, like you said, in your in your
definition of WebAssembly,
it has things like it's small, it's portable,
it's secure, it's fast.
And those things are all great in the
browser, but those are also qualities that we
want in the
workloads that we're deploying in the cloud. And
so WASP aims to give us that ability.
So
it
acts as a broker between
WebAssembly
actors or WebAssembly modules
and the nonfunctional requirements that you normally have
in cloud environments or
capabilities.
Alright. Nice. That sounds awesome.
What I'm gonna do first is just pop
up my screen
here.
So we have the WebAssembly
page here. If people wanna check that out,
they can go to webassembly.org.
The WASC homepage and also where the documentation
lies is at WASC.dev.
And if anyone is curious about the actual
book that Kevin has written, it is on
the pragmatic bookshelf available here.
So we have our first comment from a
familiar face, Brian Kesselson is saying hello. Hello,
Brian. Thanks for tuning in.
So today we're gonna get hands on with
these technologies and and try to understand, you
know, what the first steps are for someone
who is new to WebAssembly and to ask
and just how they get involved, how they
get started.
And when we spoke
just before we we started the session and
and keeping with how this stream works is
I tried to do it as little as
possible upfront.
But you did say that I I need
rust and cargo and fortunately I have those
tools installed, so I do have,
this will be its version, I do have
cargo. I do have rust. So as someone
completely new this, I mean, is step one?
So it depends on what level you wanna
start working at. So I can share my
screen and and I can show what some
of the raw WebAssembly looks like without anybody
else's tooling. So what what WebAssembly looks like
without
any bells and whistles.
Oh, yeah. Let's do that. Go for it.
Alright. So
okay.
Alright. I had to go through an awful
lot of security
prompts there.
Can you see the the tools here? The
the window? Alright.
So
like you said, WebAssembly is a byte code
format and there is a low level language
that you can use
to to write raw WebAssembly.
And so I've got a a little bit
of it here.
So this
is the the low level raw WebAssembly.
And in this one function here, if
you squint past all the parentheses, you can
see that it's adding two numbers together.
And there's a if you really want to
to work with WebAssembly,
there's a toolkit,
pronounced Webit or the WebAssembly binary toolkit.
And that has all the tools that you
need for inspecting WebAssembly files, verifying them,
trimming them down,
other types of analysis,
as well as compiling and decompiling.
So I can do,
I can use a funk a a tool
called WAT2WASM
on this file,
and it will
and it produces my,
my my WebAssembly file. And
there's another tool called WasmTime,
which is a
it's a couple of things all rolled into
one. It's a library that you can use
in Rust to run WebAssembly modules, but it's
also a a command line tool.
So I think it
it's in invoke.
Didn't prepare, so I'm I think it's just
the the the end of the wasm file
I was looking for.
There we go.
That's
oh, it's run, not invoke. Right.
Because we have had the examples and the
documentation below that did not have any reference
to that run command whatsoever.
Okay.
So we'll just pretend that that works
and move along from there. I don't wanna
waste too much time, but
It's not what is WebAssembly
text. Right? I mean Yes. So the Sorry.
I didn't go. Yeah. So the the the
WebAssembly text is the low level
language.
You can as long as your language supports
targeting WebAssembly, you can write in whatever whatever
your favorite language is.
And I certainly wouldn't recommend
people writing
in
raw WebAssembly for
anything other than really specialized purposes or just
for educational
use. But
so here's just some more functions, add, subtract,
and multiply.
But that that's
the gist of what it looks like at
the lowest level. So
no matter what tooling you're using
or
however fancy it is, Ultimately, it all boils
down to
the the the binary version of of this
text.
Okay. So the the was
the what to wasm command you run is
a compiler that takes the what format, the
WebAssembly text, and compiles that to the same
bytecode. The same as whether we use other
tools to compile rust or, you know,
TypeScript, etcetera, down into the Python bytecode.
Sure. I mean, you can call it compiling,
but it's more translation.
It's not
the
this syntax here is is
I guess, it's it's probably not worth debating
over whether you need to call it compilation
or or translation or not. But, yeah, it'll
it will convert this text into a a
binary executable WASM file.
Alright. That makes sense to me. So I
get the vibes just by looking at the
format of WebAssembly text. You kind of set
that as well as it people aren't expected
to be able to write in this format.
You know, they'll they'll be using higher level
languages that are more natural to them. Yeah.
But it's I think it's worth knowing
that this that this is what it all
you know, it's
it it it's this on the bottom because
whether you get somebody else's WebAssembly module from
the browser or
anywhere else, it it's worth knowing that
there there's nothing sacred or hidden about the
contents of a WebAssembly module. You can
anyone can examine the inside. So it's
it's not a place to put trade secrets,
especially if you're putting those out in a
browser.
Okay. That makes sense to me. Got
it. So
tell me a little bit about WASP. There
was something really interesting that you said when
you were going over the description about it,
and that's what you said it was capability
secure?
Yeah. What what does that mean?
So there's a couple of problems that WASP
is trying to solve. The first one is
to get rid of the boilerplate that we
usually write when we build microservices
and and functions in the cloud. So every
time we build a a microservice,
we have to take a dependency on some
some library
that allows us to start up an HTTP
endpoint. And we have JSON parsing and we
have
access to a database and a cache and
all this other stuff.
And we only usually end up spending five
or ten percent of our our code of
our time writing
the actual logic for our service.
So the first goal is to try and
strip away
all of those nonfunctional requirements and abstract them
into things that are satisfied outside your WebAssembly
module.
And
so those nonfunctional requirements,
we call them capabilities.
And so
your WebAssembly module
writes to an abstraction
around
a particular type of capability. So
an abstraction or an abstract contract to talk
to a key value store
or a web server, a web client,
graph database, those types of things.
And the runtime,
WASC itself
is responsible for loading your actor, your WebAssembly
module,
loading the capabilities,
and then making sure that the WebAssembly module
is allowed to communicate with that capability.
And so there's there's security embedded inside those
WebAssembly modules.
Okay. Cool.
I I just like to summarize things again
so I make sure I understand them correctly.
Mhmm. So capabilities from a WASP point of
view are the a way to enrich our
wasm code with new functionality like running a
web server.
But the bonus side of doing it in
this fashion is that you've also picked in
all of these security concerns that make sure
that the WebAssembly models actually have the ability
to invoke or call or enter interact
with those capabilities as well. So
Yeah. So
WebAssembly on its own,
the the byte code, unlike Java byte code
that has
instructions that communicate with the operating system,
WebAssembly bytecode can do no such thing. There's
there are no instructions for reading from files.
There's no instructions for making network calls. There's
no instructions for doing IO of any kind.
So
if you want your WebAssembly module to be
able to do something, it's entirely up to
the host in order to be able to
give it that capability.
So when people first start
down the road of exploring how WebAssembly can
help them, the first thing they run into
is the problem of
WebAssembly only reads and writes numbers.
The functions don't take, rich data types. So
how do you fix that problem?
And so there's a an open source project
called WAPC
that provides a
an RPC
abstraction on top of WebAssembly.
And so that fixes that problem.
And then from there, the next problem is,
well, how do I allow these WebAssembly modules
to do something more than just math or
straight up computation? How do I give them
side effects or access to cloud, capabilities?
And that's what WASP does.
Okay.
So
shall we try and build a WASC application
using some of those capabilities?
Sure.
Alright.
Are you happy for me to share my
screen? And we'll try and let's
see.
Keep us in shot. Alright.
So so what is the step one for
working with last? I go straight into writing
a rust file. Do I need to, you
know, should I cargo in it, I guess.
Right?
Cargo in your
So there's a couple of different ways you
can get started.
I think probably the easiest is to is
to use cargo generate,
and that'll build you a scaffold.
So I don't know if you have do
you have cargo generated? Okay. So cargo install,
cargo dash generate.
So this is the cargo plug in, adds
a new sub command that allows me to
generate or scaffold out a new project. Right?
Yep. And the the cool thing about this
is that the templates for the cargo generate
are just GitHub repos. So you can
it's pretty extensible. You can build any kind
of template you want. Sweet.
Alright. So we'll give that a few seconds.
Now we get to run and wait for
the infamous
rest of the time.
Yeah. Okay. Let's take a look at these
templates. Are you gonna so in my head,
I'm thinking there's either you're gonna point me
to some sort of WASC template or are
we gonna use something more generic and then
add WASC capabilities to it?
We're we're gonna start and go
right with the WASC template.
Alright. So
is that in the WASP organization?
Yep.
I I pasted it to you in chat,
but it's you could
the the repo is called new actor template,
new dash actor dash template.
Yeah. And
so that's the the scaffolding
and, you know, there there's some files with
some templates,
you know, the the handlebar type templates.
Okay. So that generate command we're gonna run.
I think it just takes github.com
forward as, like, the parameter.
Is that right?
You can use the full URL as well,
but
when you're done still not done building. When
you're done building, we can we can walk
through what the syntax is.
Alright. Okay.
My apologies. I I forgot the cargo generating
was was an add on.
I take it for granted. Like, I I
like I said, I like this to because
it's gonna be
go go through all the motions. Right? Make
no assumptions. Like, I'm if we have to
install this, we install this. I mean, other
people are gonna have to see how that
works as well. And they may not be
familiar with cargo or or or its plug
in system, etcetera.
And we're almost there, you know. It's it's
chugging along.
I bet it slows down there.
I'm gonna take a read Let's compile a
piece of code on the Internet before giving
you the the plug in.
Alright. Okay.
So that is what I'm gonna get spat
out the other side once I run this
generate command with this template. I can kinda
see
what's happening here. Yeah.
We can kinda go through that now if
you want. We can take a look at
that, that source file.
Yeah. Right.
Too funny.
So,
basically, what we have is,
WASC treats,
WebAssembly files or WebAssembly modules as actors that
conform to the actor model. And
as a result, they are reactive.
So the way
WASP actors interact with the the rest of
the world is by handling messages. So
on line 19 there, there's a macro that
defines
the the handlers that you use.
And
that's actually gonna get everything you see here
is actually gonna get a little bit simpler
probably within the next week and a half
or so. We're we're doing a bunch of
fairly major changes.
And
so this says that it handles an HTTP
request and it handles a
a health request.
And
so the HTTP request is fairly straightforward. You
get one as input and you return one
as output,
and you return a response as output.
But what's interesting there is
nowhere in this file do you see
the creation of an HTTP server
or the configuration of an endpoint
or any nonfunctional requirements at all for that
matter. All you're doing is declaring that you
handle web requests and you return an HTTP
response.
And every time you're asked whether your actor
is healthy, you, return okay, which is
Rust speak for,
no errors.
Okay.
Alright. We've got two more to go. So
I'm gonna assume we'll be able to generate
that in just a second.
Come on, Rust.
So I do like the the brevity of
this code here, you know, using using this
macro syntax to just define and hook up
these two functions to the actual the web
server capability is is nice. Like, I wish
all my code was this simple to write.
That's good to hear.
You know,
one of the biggest goals that we have
with West is to make it easier to
write microservices and functions. And so
the the closer you can get to just
being able to declare your business logic,
the better.
I I Definitely. You know, especially with micro
services and cloud native generally just becoming so
prominent these days. Like, the amount of time
spent working with traditional web based frameworks. You
know, there's just so much boilerplate. Even just
such that, you know, simple things like routing.
Just You've got to build all this out
yourself and that's Yep. I think it gets
worse when you try and go from your
initial
experiments. I think you have to do dash
dash get before that URL.
Alright. Thanks.
There we go.
Yeah. So when you try and take your
initial experiment to production,
you end up with this problem where the
boilerplate that you started with is no longer
sufficient and you have to add more and
more boilerplate. You have to add stuff for
monitoring and and observability
and
tracing and logging and error handling and all
of that stuff.
And so by the time you're done,
you can no you you can no longer
even find your business logic in the spaghetti
pile of boilerplate that you've added.
And then after you've deployed the production, if
you wanna change your business logic,
it's a nightmare, because you're carrying with you
all of these, dependencies and the transitive dependencies.
That that rule about
you owning your dependencies
is,
very, very true and
all the pain that comes with it.
Yeah. So this is pretty I think it's
identical to the the code that that we
were looking at on GitHub.
It is. I'm kinda curious then. So
is this just regular active stuff or is
this capability stuff that the code There
is no active in this
at all. And,
you know, if you've been watching me complain
about active on Twitter,
all of the tactics that I'm using is
in the host runtime. I I would I
would never ever subject
regular developers to any of that pain. So
this is all just
straight up pure Rust.
And you can write actor modules in Rust,
TinyGo,
AssemblyScript,
or Zig.
Oh, really? I didn't know that. Okay. So
last doesn't force me to write Rust?
Nope.
That's one of the benefits of WebAssembly
is is polyglot nature. Right? So as long
as the language that you're target that you're
writing knows how to satisfy that WAPC
function call contract between the host and the
guest, you can write an actor in that
language.
Okay. So that means that the, you know,
the last team you and, you know, the
other contributors,
you're providing like SDKs or API layers or
something available for for go and for rust
and for
So yeah. Essentially.
So
one of the the things that we're we're
changing is so if you if you hover
over on I'm I'm pointing at my screen
as if you can see that.
You hover over,
one of those constants on line 19,
the, like, the the handle request,
you'll see that that's that's that thing is
defined in a create called West codec,
which holds all of these common data types
that we use for things like key value
store the the key value store abstraction, the
web server abstraction, all of that.
That's the old way of doing things. And
by old way, I mean, last week.
The what we're doing now is we're using
the WAPC
code generator.
And so we have schemas that we can
define in
standard
text format
and then generate all the data types that
we need for our actors regardless of what
language we're in. So there's a code generator
for
that will convert a schema to a a
Rust template.
There's one that will convert it into TinyGo
and one that will convert it into AssemblyScript.
And so
we no longer even need this shared codec
which becomes
we all know how much of a pain
in the butt these shared libraries are. Anytime
you you take a shared mutual dependency on
something,
that thing is invariably gonna,
catch fire and and cause all sorts of
problems.
So with the code generated version of this,
everything that's in that codec would actually just
be generated and inside your project.
Okay.
So
let's see if you can fill in a
few of the blanks for me here Mhmm.
And try and help me understand what what
is going on. So I understand that the
bank syntax here is rust. It means I've
got a macro. I can see that we're
passing in constants, which are then being, you
know, resolved to the functions that we have
here.
Yep. How
like, what what would the h t p
request look like to call this? Is this
just gonna be on slash?
Is this, you know, a head request? How
does this map to h t t p?
So
that's
and it it's a really good question. And
so what you have is
you're declaring that you're going to handle an
HTTP request with this hello world function, and
all of the information in that request is
actually contained inside that data type, the the
HTTP
request.
What you what, URLs you handle and how
you handle them is entirely up to you,
and that's inside,
And that would be done inside,
the hello world function.
So the the query string, the headers,
all of that stuff is,
just properties on the request,
struct.
But Okay.
Things like
what port number your web server is gonna
start on
and how many threads it's gonna use and
all of that other stuff,
that is all runtime configuration
that you supply to WASC. And so when
WASC binds your actor
to the HTTP
server capability provider,
it'll do so with whatever configuration you supply,
which includes
the the port number.
Okay. That's that has
just you can over that as well as
in a few blanks there. Okay. So the
actual the only HTTP request we are handling
is hello world. The health is actually a
core. It's not HTTP. So that was just
I thought we had two HTTP endpoints were
being
rooted in some fashion.
Really, what we're saying is hello world is
like an entry point to for a less
HTTP server and then Yep. I can handle
anything specific that I wanna do. Yeah. So
if you if you wanted to define routing
logic that would go inside your hello world
function.
The health function is something that the last
run time calls on your actor in order
to make sure that it's still up and
running.
And so if for whatever reason you
you either can't answer that function or that
function crashes or you explicitly return an error,
then WASP will treat your actor as as
down. And,
you know, depending on how the runtime is
configured, it'll restart it or take
whatever action it needs.
Okay. Cool. That makes sense.
Can we run this then? There's a there's
a couple more steps, but, yeah, we should
be able to run it.
Alright. What's the what's the next step? So
there's
some tooling that you need to install.
Alright.
So like I said earlier,
WASC,
is secure by default. That means that every
one of the WebAssembly modules has to have
a signed JSON web token embedded inside it
so that that module
carries with it the list of,
you can call them entitlements,
but the the thing the the capabilities that
it's allowed to use.
And so,
if you take a look at the make
file here,
you
should see
online 31 there. It's actually
using
one of the tools to sign the
WebAssembly
module.
And
that dash I
in the and
yeah. The the dash s on that command
line
entitles that module to communicate
with the HTTP server capability.
Okay. So what we need to do is
people first, we need to generate the keys,
and then we need to sign it.
And so that requires installing two tools right
now. But
like I said, we're we're right in the
middle of of changing a bunch of things.
And so
we have a bunch of little tiny tools,
and we're converting that to just one tool
so that you you can install that one
tool and do all of the development tasks.
So the the first thing you want to
install is a tool called n keys.
And so Install? Cargo install
n keys, and I think we need dash
dash features
and then quote CLI.
Space
space quote CLI. Yeah.
I'll start another one. What was the other
tool we need? And I'll get that run.
The other tool is called Westcap.
And,
again, we all we need the the CLI
features.
And that's the tool for
embedding
the signed tokens inside the WebAssembly modules.
So what happens there is that inside
every one of those WebAssembly modules when we
create this token, because it's cryptographically signed,
we can verify
that it was signed by who it claims
to have been signed by. But then the
last runtime can make,
you know, runtime security decisions so we can
verify the provenance chain of that module. So
you can do things like decide,
was this module signed by our
one valid production environment issuer?
If not, you can't run it. Or was
it signed by one of the four or
five accounts that we trust in development or
QA
or, you know, that sort of thing.
And we have a a a plug in
system so you can
you can even defer your runtime security decisions
to
Open Policy Agent.
Oh, sweet. So
the the OPA,
RIGO files, they have built into them the
ability to process JSON web tokens.
So what we do is we just send
the token from the WebAssembly module
over to OPA, and then you can write
your own policy to to to determine how
you want to to authorize
it.
Okay. I'm
definitely gonna have to take a look at
that at some point.
Let's try
and okay. We won't watch that compile. But
let's
you know, I know a little bit of
rust, you know. I'm writing rust regularly.
What how does my workflow change here then
with regards to, you know,
like logging? Like,
can I just use the standard tools? Is
there something that was provides on top of
that to simplify it?
Do I add debug messages?
So there's there's two different ways you can
do it in
in any of the languages that we support.
One is there there's always a console log
function
that's available when you write this. So
yeah. Console underscore log. I think it's
of course, you're not getting any suggestions.
Thanks. Anyway,
analyzer running.
I'm not sure why it's not Yeah. Part
of the reason why I I stopped using
Versus Code is because
it usually takes between thirty seconds and two
minutes to stop giving me auto completion help.
So
there it is.
So that function will will write to standard
out,
as long as the the last the the
runtime you're you're using allows it. There's a
more
robust logging provider that Brian Kettleson actually wrote
that
allows you to do things like log at
specific levels. So you can say, you you
can use the,
the debug and info and trace macros
directly inside your actor.
And then for that to work, your actor
needs to be entitled to use the WASC
logger, capability.
Okay. And the WASP the so okay. So
let's recover that because I think you mentioned
that in the earlier. The way I add
capabilities
is by adding new parameters to the build
step here.
Yeah. So there are a couple of well
known capabilities that Waskap will has
shortcuts for. So one of them is the
HTTP server
and so on. But you can also there's
nothing preventing you. In fact, you're encouraged to
write your own custom capability providers. And so
you can use Westcap or,
you know, next week, you'll be able to
use the new tool,
to,
sign with any capability ID. And so each
each one of these abstract contracts between actors
and a capability has,
essentially a contract ID.
And
so there's there's one called West Redis.
Sorry. Not West Redis. West key value.
And so that that contract ID says that
it's a key value
contract.
It can be satisfied by Redis or Cassandra
or Memcached or an in process
cache,
but the contract itself remains the same. And
so when we authorize actors, we authorize them
to use the abstract contract.
And then at runtime, we can decide how
to bind them to specific providers.
Okay.
I think I understood.
And I I think I understand that. Okay.
We tell our application is allowed to do
some sort of key values get and set,
and then the run time will actually will
inject its own provider specific implementation?
Yeah. So when we
when we configure the run time so we
start at West Coast, and then we tell
it to load whatever actors we want to
load. And then we tell it to load
capability
providers. So I can tell it to load
the Redis provider or,
whatever other provider I want.
And then we supply configuration
to bind an actor to a provider. So
in this case, we could we could bind
your actor to
the Redis provider, and that will allow it
to access
the the key value store.
Okay. Yeah. That that The other thing one
of the other things that we allow
is
you can actually stop the
provider at runtime and replace it with a
different one, and the actor will not will
will not know. So I could switch between
Redis and Cassandra at runtime and the actor
won't won't stop running. It won't even miss
any requests.
So how does how does that work? Like,
if the runtime is in the middle of
swapping that out and requests are coming in
and and they just paused
until the provider is satisfied again?
Yep. It just pauses it. So the requests
coming the requests coming in to the actor
will queue up while
the provider is unavailable. And then once you,
put in the new provider, the the actor
will, essentially unpause.
And we can do the same thing with
actors. We can live update them
from, you know, version one to version two
without them missing requests. So if it's bound
to an HTTP server,
that that web server
will continue sending the actor requests, but they'll
just queue up while the actor is being
updated.
And we don't need to scale out in
order to do that live update. We don't
need to provision any transient resources.
We can just do it live.
Okay. That that's that's quite impressive.
Definitely.
Alright.
I mean, I'm too scared to go look
at the Rust compilation. I'll assume it's either
done or almost done. One more question on
the capabilities then. So if I've got an
application that has access to the key value
provider,
Do I have the ability to say that
it can only read on that capability rather
than read and write? Like, can I get
really specific with what the service is able
to do?
So there's an issue in the backlog where
we're gonna add that functionality.
So right now,
you either have access to that contract or
you don't. So you can either access the
key value store or you can't.
Once we implement this feature, we'll have the
fine grained control, like you said, and and
you'll essentially be able to
so if you if you go back to,
the source file,
you'll see
the
the the lib file. If you look
the that
op handle request is a constant that just
applies
to
an operation called handle request.
And so
when we implement this new feature, we'll be
able to say
that you have access to the web server
capability provider,
and you you can invoke this operation.
And so that operation is,
in this case, it's handled request. But you
could do for the key value store, you
can say,
you have access to the key value store,
but you can only invoke
the
the set operation
or
the list members
operation.
And so you can
you can control it down to the individual
operations.
Alright. Excellent.
Rust has
graciously finished. So
I'm assuming based on the make fail we
just looked at, that should make keys. Make
keys. Yep.
See, I often when there's a make fail
in a project on their own directory. Because
it just makes everything so much easier.
Okay. So you see now we've we've created
an account key and a module key. And
so the account is the the issuer of
the module. That's the and then the module
itself is
is the actor. And so
every actor in this system has a globally
unique public key as do,
all of the accounts.
And this
that becomes
critically important when we get into
the our clustering technology called Lattice.
Okay.
Clustering technology?
So
what you're doing right now is is building
actors that are gonna run-in a West Coast.
But West Coasts can
detect each other and self form self healing
clusters.
And so when you tell it to run
an actor,
it will just run anywhere on any of
the discovered hosts.
And if you tell it to run a
capability provider, it'll run anywhere on any of
the discovered hosts. And
by discovered hosts, it this the lattice essentially
flattens any topology that it discovers. So I
could have a bunch of hosts running in
my DigitalOcean environment.
I could have,
eight of them running on Raspberry Pis,
which I actually do
over there.
And you could have them running in your
Google environment or
anywhere else, you know, on prem inside your
enterprise.
And as long as those are able to
find each other
at all, then WASP treats them as essentially
one flat
target of potential compute.
Wow. Okay. So I'm gonna summarize that again
for my own benefit here.
The WASC run time isn't just single node.
You can actually run it across multiple nodes.
I'm not sure how the discovery works. Maybe
we can talk about that later. But they
have the ability to then schedule
the WASC actors across any of those nodes,
and the messaging is all handled for me
across nodes. Like, I don't need to I
don't need to know where each actor is
running as that kind of No. No. And
in fact, because we
WASP is an an opinionated framework.
So it takes the opinion that you shouldn't
have to know or care
physically where your actors are running. All you
should care about is logically where they're running.
So you want to be able to tune
your,
your cluster of compute so that if you
want this particular actor to run-in close network
proximity to this particular capability provider,
you can do so. But you shouldn't care
that it's running on this host in DigitalOcean
and this host and this other one. Right?
Being able to do things like
when I do,
when I list my nodes in Kubernetes,
I don't care what hosts they're running on.
All I care is that they're up. And
if I want more, I should just be
able to fire up more hosts. And
it's not that simple in Kubernetes.
And so I wanted to make it that
simple with West. So if I want to
increase the size of my lattice,
I just go find some new place where
I'm not yet running a WASC coast. I
run a WASC coast
and as long as that WASC coast can
establish
a NAT's leaf node communication
with any of my other
subnets, it's all one flat topology.
Okay.
I mean,
you've thrown me for a sec here. Like,
I I I always go into these streams
thinking I understand the technology, and I I
I just realized how little I actually knew
about Wasco and just how much it actually
does for you. That is awesome. Like that
Yeah. So like
I said, the the the first problem we
wanted to solve is getting rid of boilerplate.
And by getting rid of that boilerplate,
it enables a whole bunch of other things
that we can make easier as well. So
part of the problem that we have when
building cloud services is that everything we do
is
compile time coupled to all of the services
that we consume.
And, you know, we can we can tell
ourselves that it's easy to to decouple those
things and we can write anti corruption lawyers
and all this other stuff, but
we're still tightly coupled at at runtime.
But being loosely coupled at runtime means that
we can dynamically dispatch between our actors and
the things that they need in order to
do their jobs.
And because we can dynamically dispatch,
we can make the actors and the providers
unaware of how that dispatch happens.
So that can be locally in process when
you're only wanting one node when you're only
running one node,
but it can be,
spanning multiple
cloud environments
when you're running multiple cloud environments.
And neither the providers nor the actors
need to be changed or recompiled or redeployed
in order to scale up or down.
So I can run one
actor in one host on my laptop
when I'm developing.
And then
one of the goals we have is that
I should never have to change my business
logic
to scale from experiments
to production.
So I should be able to go from
from napkin drawing to production
in one straight line. And I should just
be able to turn the knob and say,
I want one of these running or I
want 500 of them running.
And
to not have to worry about that because
it's one of the opinions that we take
on on on the framework.
Okay. Cool.
Do have another question. But before I ask
it, should I run make build? Will that
take long?
It shouldn't take any it it shouldn't take
any time at all.
Oh, yes.
You need to do
Rust up target add.
Wasm 32 dash unknown dash unknown.
So
if you're not familiar with it,
Rust come by default comes with a target
that matches your operating system and architecture.
And the WebAssembly binary file
is both architecture
and
operating system agnostic,
and so you have to install a separate
target for it.
Okay. Sweet.
Alright. Okay. I'll come back to my question
where we let that quickly run through, though.
It's like it's gonna be finished any Yeah.
Quickly.
So
see when I run so I've told Wask
that I wanna have an actor that listens
on h two two p and just spits
out some arbitrary payload.
Is that actor running all the time or
does Wask schedule that when messages hit the
mailbox?
So right now, the West Coast is operating
in a in a way where that's running
all the time.
There's
nothing preventing you from
so Wask,
long story short, is,
there is a control plane, and the protocol
for the control plane is a known thing.
So if you wanted to write
a tool that monitored the events in the
lattice
and decided when to scale something from one
to zero,
you could do so.
It's not something that's that that we ship
with out of the box,
but
all of the tools are there in order
to make that happen.
Nice. My my use case I had in
my head there is I was looking I
can't remember if it's called New Orleans or
Orleans, but the event sourcing framework and from
the the dot net world. And they have
a concept of virtual actors where the actor
isn't actually running until the message sets the
mailbox. And, like, for events or systems where
you potentially have millions of actors like that,
to me, it's a really cool approach.
One of the issues we have in our
backlog is
to build an open fast gateway.
And so
what what that'll essentially amount to is that
any actor that's bound to the open fast
capability
provider
will be exposed as though it's an open
fast function.
And in that case, we can, when we
write that gateway, we can write it in
such a way that we can
scale that actor to zero.
So,
essentially, what you'll be able to do is
use all the open fast tools
to talk to actors running in a lattice.
Now that I wanna play with. Like,
I'll subscribe to that issue in the backlog.
That sounds awesome.
Alright.
Let's go back to our code. We've
compiled it.
Let's see. If I look in the target
directory
and then the wasm
debug,
we have our wasm file.
So now if there's a command you can
run
called called Westcap, which is where all the
security comes from. So if you do Westcap,
space caps,
and then
give it the path to your signed WebAssembly
module.
K. So target debug plasm.
I got it. Oh, plasm.
Debug
and then
the
same one. Right. Okay. So main. Why did
I call it main and not my? I
don't know what what happened there.
Naming is always hard. You want the signed
version of that file?
Signed.
Alright. So this is a tool that exposes
the capabilities that are
that are part of this this afterward. Yeah.
So right now, can see that the the
account,
that's the issuer. So that's that's the thing
that that vouched for this module. And so,
you know, in in production, we could have
a very limited set of accounts that we
trust or maybe even just one.
Whereas in on our laptop, we don't really
care, and we can use any account we
want. But,
again, the the the the opinion here
is that the binary itself
doesn't change.
We don't need to make changes to our
code or to our binary
in order to go from
tinkering
in a lab to running in production.
So we can set expiration
times on these just like you could with
any other JSON web token.
So one thing you can do for
enterprise
security is make it so that that token
expires so that the modules have to be
resigned periodically,
which if you're
exceptionally paranoid about certain types of intrusion,
this would
block off that particular type of attack vector
where someone if if someone compromised one of
these modules, which is highly unlikely,
you could limit the amount of time
that that comp compromise lasts.
Okay. What's the tags at the bottom?
So tags are just arbitrary tags that you
can stick on these modules that will be
embedded in there.
It's essentially just, free form metadata that you
can put on there. You can use those
types of tags for,
informing
a custom scheduler that you write if you
want.
When we when we built an online game
out of,
WASC actors,
we used the tags to
so the the game was essentially you build
WebAssembly robots, and then,
all of these robots compete in the same
online virtual arena over a a Lattice.
And, obviously, the most important thing for that
was to have a cool avatar for each
one of the robots.
So the the tag actually represented the name
of the avatar icon that they were gonna
use.
Okay. But, again, it's it's free form, so
you can assign whatever meaning to it you
want.
Can
right. I keep getting stuff ideas that pop
into my head now. I I'm thinking if
there was like an intent based system
where I could say I wanna I wanna
send a message to an actor that fulfills
this intent, like resizing images or something. Could
I use the tags to enable that kind
of discovery of other actors?
Yep.
So
we don't we don't have the ability to
to send messages to actors
that fulfill some set of criteria
offhand.
But again, you can use that Lattice protocol
to do so. So you could query all
of the actors in the in the Lattice,
find out which ones meet your criteria. So
they could be ones tagged a certain way,
And then you get your list of actors
back, and then you could just,
you know, send those RPC calls in a
for loop.
Yeah. I I think we just invented the
service mesh for mass for WASC.
We need to build that now.
Okay. So do I use WasmTime to run
this, or do I use
WASC? So
we need we need the WASC host,
which is another
binary that we I think we have to
install through cargo.
And the features on that one is bin,
not CLI.
I'm not sure why that's inconsistent.
Probably
just
a little coffee day for me.
And is it last fast host or just
last host? Okay.
And you should, I believe, get o dot
13.
The open fast gateway is set for o
dot 15.
So it's it's right around the corner.
Excellent.
I think the open fast stuff would be
really cool, actually.
Well, the thing that I I think is
so exciting about it is that with this
this
ability to dynamically
stitch itself together to form this flat network.
And then that flat network having a control
plane that talks to the entire thing as
though we're a single topology
means that you can use it as the
foundation to build any kind of tool that
you want built.
So all of this extra stuff that you
can put on top of it, whether you
want an open fast gateway or a gateway
to some other cool thing,
really, all you need to do is just
put
something on the lattice that that speaks the
control plane and you're good to go.
So with regard it's just because we're kinda
vaguely talking about integrations and other parts of
software there. And you've also covered the fact
that last can handle HTTP requests coming in.
With regards to other providers, like, does it
support Kafka, NATs? Like, what are the other
touch points for people to get something to
There are there are a bunch of first
party providers that we wrote that that are
that we essentially are guaranteeing that we're gonna
support going forward so that those things will
always be updated. And so that's,
the web server, the web client.
There's,
Redis key value client.
an AWS Lambda provider. So if you bind
your actor to the AWS Lambda provider,
your WASP actor can essentially run as if
it were an AWS Lambda.
And there's a couple of other ones including
nets as a message broker.
But
the
the capability provider system is a plug in
system,
and the protocol that we use to
bind to the capability providers is all a
a publicly known thing, and it's just a
standard schema. So
it's designed specifically
to
encourage you to build your own capability providers.
So one of the the the key scenarios
we see for it is, you know, enterprises
often have a whole bunch of internal services
that they provide for their own application developers.
And so being able to encapsulate those
as,
say, a private enterprise only capability provider
It could be something that enterprises would use
for,
you know, making it easier to build internal
software.
Yeah. That makes sense. Okay.
And I take it the the the effort
to provide a to build your own
capability and provider, etcetera.
I mean, how much effort is there involved
in doing something like that?
In building your own capability provider,
it's not that much.
Today, you know, it probably takes well so
you saw that there was a template to
build an actor. There's a template to build
a capability provider. So you can essentially cargo
generate yourself a custom one,
and and you'll get
it's I think it's called new provider template.
I'm just gonna search template and pull them
all up.
There it is. I just alright. So provide
alright. Okay. First one.
So if you look there,
there's essentially two requirements for a capability provider.
The first is that you expose a descriptor,
which is the the metadata for which operations
that provider supports,
what direction they flow in,
and what capability contract it satisfies.
So whether it's a key value provider or
a graph database provider or whether it's a
a custom contract that you just made up
on your own.
And then you just have to implement
a function that takes the dispatcher from West,
which is, you know, that's your RPC gateway.
That's the thing that allows you to to
make function calls on actors.
And then you need to accept function calls
from actors,
and that's it.
Alright. So the sentence is only a hundred
and four lines of code.
And most of that is comments, really.
Nice. So if you see if you scroll
down to the bottom, you'll see the list
of operations that you need to support out
of the box.
There's bind actor, which as its name implies,
you get one of those when a binding
is supplied between an actor and a provider.
So the web server
will take that bind actor message, grab the
HTTP port, and then start a web server.
Remove actor, you use to dispose of the
resources that you had, that were allocated to
a given actor before.
And then get capability descriptor is the the
metadata operation that West Coast uses to to
pull data from.
Oh, cool. Okay.
Alright. Let's go back and oh, I broke
it.
Oh, yeah.
So remember earlier when I say what could
possibly happen?
So what has happened here is
the version of West that you're downloading
is using,
a dependent it's using a version of n
keys
that you have,
in your cache
that is
it's not compatible with,
an encryption library,
you know, like, grates down in that dependency
tree.
So,
I I don't think you're actually gonna be
able to show it,
here.
There's a a release I need to cut
literally today that should fix this problem.
But
long story short is the the the Rust
Nets client
needs to be o dot eight dot one.
And
so I needed to update the dependencies to
that, and I have I just haven't done
that today. So it looks like there's a
a a build
break here or at least an install break.
So can I install a different version of
last calls, like 12 for FLR? Is it
just
No. More than more
than likely, what I'm gonna have to do
is release o 13 dot one,
which fixes the dependency chain because that's that's
easier than you trying to manually figure out
how to fix o dot 12.
So
my apologies there.
No. That's okay. I I mean, I think
we've had a a really
I mean, just a conversation around the responsibilities
and what was is bringing to the table,
why it's it's, you know, killing people should
use it. It's it's been really interesting for
me. I've learned so much,
you know.
One thing I can there's one more thing
I can show,
which kind of shows you how to run
it,
which
isn't
I'm I'm a little disappointed that we can't
actually run it live, but, you know, that's
that's just how things work.
I'm trying to get a URL here for
you.
Would you be able to run it on
your machine? Do you have a working WASC?
I wish I should hope so.
Oh, you know what?
On my machine, I have the full async
rewrite of
West Coast in progress.
So,
that's
even then, I I don't think I can
I I I can't run the old demos?
Let me let me send you this URL
now.
So
when you when you start the West Coast,
you,
you you start it with a manifest file
that should look suspiciously
like,
you know, a Kubernetes type manifest or something.
But,
basically, what you do is you list off
the actors you wanna run-in the host, the
capability providers you wanna run-in the host, and
then the bindings between them.
And so in the bindings here, you'll see
the that key that starts with an m
is the actor's public key, and you can
get that by examining the the caps or
the capabilities on that module.
And so this
the binding there between thirteen and sixteen
essentially says that that actor is going to
get the Redis capability provider,
and it's going to use,
you know, that red that value for the
URL.
And it's going to set that same actor
up with an HTTP server,
running at port eighty eighty one.
And
so what's
what's happening,
as as we speak is there are issues
being worked on in the backlog where we're
essentially going to adopt the the OEM, the
open application model
for
so that you can use an OEM
YAML
to describe a distributed manifest.
So you say,
here, I want these actors and these bindings
with these host affinities and these other settings.
Go and make that happen in the Lattice.
I don't care how you do it, and
and and that's what'll happen.
Nice.
Okay. So
awesome.
I think what I'll do is I'll come
back to this once you've cut off the
the release. Will that be sometime this week
or next week? Just to
I I I wanna play with this more.
So I should be able to issue that
patch release today. So Alright.
Well, that's cool.
Let me pop off my screen.
I mean, the the the short of it
is that there some of these transitive dependencies
allow
patch version upgrades to happen automatically.
And in some cases, those patch versions are
were actually breaking changes. So people people aren't
following the Semper rules.
Alright.
Well, we'll we'll come back to that. We'll
get that running another time. Is there anything
else you wanna talk about or show just
before we finish up for today?
There are a couple YouTube videos that people
can watch that have,
you know, some some live demos of things,
you know, back in the good old days
when they worked.
Let me see if I can get a
link to the playlist.
Welcome.
Yeah.
Let's
alright. So I'll I'll let me just send
you a link to this playlist.
Alright. Let's drop that in here.
And, you know, that that goes through some
slide where but you can fast forward to
the the cool parts with the demos and
see things running.
Alright. Well, that link is now in there.
Sorry. On your go, Kevin. Sorry.
I think maybe
sometime next week, we'll be able to show
the new single tool that does all of
the CLI stuff for you without having to
install multiple different ones.
We're also gonna make that tool available through
things like brew and a p t and
whatnot so you don't have to use cargo
install
because
nobody needs to sit and watch Rust rebuild
things.
So, yeah, things are get definitely gonna get
a lot smoother
in the next week or two.
Awesome. Well, I posted that link into the
comments. I will add it to the show
notes afterwards when I go back over this.
Just to summarize, Alaska is really cool. It's
written in Rust, an active driven system for
capability secure workloads
that
works in a distributed cluster nature
with the lattice, which is amazing.
And I think there's just and and the
velocity of the project, you know, you're talking
about these things that are coming in the
in the road map, you know, open gap,
open fast gateways.
It's just all really exciting. I'm really looking
forward to seeing where this project goes. So
I'll also include all the links in the
GitHub and the show notes so people can
go and hopefully,
you know, do some hacktober hacking, you know,
find some good first issues and see if
you can contribute to the last project.
Thank you very much for joining me today,
Kevin. This is really insightful. I learned an
absolute ton and I'm looking forward to playing
with it some more. Great. Thanks for having
me. Alright. My pleasure. Have a good day.
You too.